"N'as-tu jamais fait un de ces rêves qui ont l'air plus vrai que la réalité ?
Si tu étais incapable de sortir de l'un de ces rêves,
comment ferais-tu la différence entre le monde réel et le monde des rêves ?"
Citation de Morpheus dans Matrix, parce qu’aujourd’hui
nous faisons la suite de ma première vidéo sur les rêves lucides.
" Rêves Lucides - 2 - "
Générique !
Cette année, je vous avais fait une vidéo sur les rêves lucides et récemment
je vous ai fait une autre vidéo sur "comment se souvenir des rêves".
Et vous m'avez reparlé des rêves lucides,
donc je vous fais une suite.
J'ai regardé également un petit peu ce qui se faisait
dans d'autres vidéos,
ça ne sert à rien que je redise les choses
qui sont déjà bien traitées sur youtube
et je me suis aperçu qu'on n'a pas trop parlé des pièges.
Il y a trois pièges principaux quand on veut
essayer de faire des rêves lucides
ou quand on fait des rêves lucides.
Le premier piège : c'est l'impatience et l'inconstance.
Ça peut être très long d'arriver à faire un rêve lucide,
moi j'ai mis plus de six mois
en utilisant des méthodes précises,
comme celles que je vous avais expliquées
la première fois
ou celles que je vais vous redonner aujourd'hui.
Et, en plus, la première fois qu'on arrive
à faire un rêve lucide
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va y arriver
facilement la deuxième fois.
Ça prend du temps.
On peut être amené à lâcher un petit peu.
Ou à être inconstant dans les méthodes.
Un jour vous y arriverez obligatoirement.
Imaginez, j'ai mis plus de six mois,
je vous l'ai dit. C'est long six mois.
C'est très très long.
Donc il faut persévérer.
Le deuxième piège c'est le Deus ex machina,
le sentiment d'omnipotence,
Dites vous que lorsque vous faites un rêves lucide
vous êtes en train de discuter
entre votre conscient et votre inconscient.
Donc l'inconscient fabrique le décor, les personnages, un petit peu les situations, certaines actions...
Et vous, comme vous êtes conscient, vous pouvez peut-être maîtriser ça
et décider de ce que vous allez faire.
Mais comme dans tout dialogue,
si vous décidez de tout,
si vous décidez de changer le décor en permanence,
de changer les personnages en permanence,
si vous décidez de prendre une conscience complète,
du fait que c'est vous qui êtes à l'origine de tout ça :
alors le rêve va commencer à devenir un petit peu creux,
un petit peu plat
voire à s'arrêter,
ce qui va provoquer le réveil.
Parce que, comme dans n'importe quel dialogue,
si l'un des deux n'écoute plus,
l'autre se tait et part.
Votre inconscient est en train de
vous envoyer des messages,
de vous donner des informations sur
ce que vous pensez profondément,
sur ce qui le perturbe lui,
sur ce qu'il a envie de vous dire.
Ne cherchez pas à tout maîtriser,
du coup,
laissez le s'exprimer.
Et le troisième piège dans lequel on peut tomber,
suit logiquement ce deuxième piège :
c'est la satisfaction permanente de ses désirs.
Au départ, quand on fait des rêves lucides,
on veut juste satisfaire ses envies,
à savoir :
voler,
pour la plupart d'entre nous ;
satisfaire des délires, je ne sais pas moi...
aller dans l'espace, être une rockstar... ;
satisfaire sa libido.
Oui je le sais...
Bon, c'est tout à fait normal
mais si vous faites ça en permanence
vous allez perdre votre motivation.
Et, encore une fois, vous n'allez pas laisser le loisir complet à votre inconscient de s'exprimer.
Ça reste quand même une belle manière
de résoudre ses conflits psychologiques,
de se connaître un petit peu mieux soi-même.
C'est aussi une forme de développement personnel.
Mais quand vous croisez quelqu'un dans le rêve,
n'hésitez pas à discuter avec cette personne,
n'hésitez pas à interagir avec elle
et à savoir ce qu'elle veut vous dire,
puisque, en fait,
c'est votre inconscient qui parle
et c'est le meilleur moyen
de parler avec vous-même.
Un des meilleurs conseils pour faire
des rêves lucides,
reste le travail qu'a fait Paul Tholey à ce sujet,
c'est le premier à avoir parlé de l'importance
de l'esprit critique dans un rêve lucide.
Remettez en cause en permanence la réalité,
régulièrement demandez vous ce que
vous faisiez il y a cinq minutes,
il y a dix minutes,
est-ce que tout est normal ?
Est-ce que c'est normal qu'il soit cette heure-ci ?
Est-ce que vous avez l'habitude d'être là ?
Quand on rêve, on perd complètement
son esprit critique.
C'est pour çà qu'on n'analyse pas toutes ces choses
complètement surprenantes et incroyables.
Puisque c'est notre réalité,
on ne la remet pas en question.
Donc, remettez en question régulièrement la réalité,
dans la réalité,
et vous allez commencer aussi à le faire,
par réflexe, dans vos rêves.
Comme pour vous souvenir de vos rêves,
tenez un journal des rêves.
Ça c'est important.
Vous pouvez également vous imprégner
avant de vous endormir, vous préparer.
Habituez votre inconscient
à votre habitude du rêve lucide,
c'est à dire : regarder beaucoup de vidéos
sur les rêves lucides ;
lisez sur les rêves lucides ;
parlez du rêve lucide avec les autres personnes...
et comme ça fait partie de votre quotidien,
votre inconscient va ramener ça aussi la nuit
et donc va vous aider.
Et vous pouvez bien sûr utiliser des stimuli,
comme les odeurs ou les sons.
Il y a certaines applications qui servent
aux rêves lucides.
Il y en a une qui s'appelle "Smart Alarm",
elle t'envoie des sons durant la nuit
sur le rêve que tu voudrais faire
pour essayer de te sortir un peu du sommeil
d'entendre ça
et de prendre conscience que tu es en train de rêver.
Si vous avez d'autres conseils
ou une expérience de rêve lucide
que vous voudriez partager,
n'hésitez pas à nous en faire part dans les commentaires,
on pourra échanger et se lire ça.
Je souris parce que je sais déjà
qu'il y a des rêves lucides
qui vont être WTF.
N'hésitez pas à nous mettre tout ça,
c'est drôle et c'est intéressant en même temps.
Et quant à moi, dans la description,
je vais vous mettre deux bouquins
que je recommande,
je vous les ai déjà recommandés dans la première vidéo
je vous les recommande de nouveau aujourd'hui.
Principalement les livres de Stephen Laberge
qui a fait d'énormes travaux là-dessus
et qui m'ont beaucoup aidé.
Et n'oubliez pas :
gardez l'esprit critique sur la réalité
en permanence.
Prenez cette habitude là,
pour la retrouver en rêve.
J'espère que cette deuxième vidéo sur le sujet
vous aura plu.
Comme d'habitude vous pouvez laisser un like
et vous abonner à la chaîne
et rendez-vous demain à 17h.
CIAO !